hello guys and welcome to another video
so sam ramy has finally spoke about no
way home and here is what he has to say
about it it was so much fun remy said i
love no way home and the audience i was
with went crazy it was delightful to
watch alfred play his role and william
defoe just seeing these guys take it to
the next level and toby was awesome as
always the best word i can say is that
it was very refreshing for me so sam
remy here is clearly happy with what he
has seen and it must feel good to just
watch these characters from a fan
perspective for once um he's worked with
these actors and his own films but to
see them taken off from a different
director and to be happy with what they
did with the characters must be such a
great villain and now sam remy is back
in the directing role and he is
directing the upcoming doctor strange
two in the multiverse of madness there
are actually rumors going around that
toby maguire will show up in this film
um i will say take that with a massive
grain of salt now while we're on the
topic of doctor strange in a multiverse
of madness in the same interview rami
actually spoke about it and he responded
to the reports of the big re-suits
happening back in november he said i
think we're done but we just cut
everything we're just starting to test
the picture and we'll find out if
there's anything that's got to be picked
up if something's unclear or another
improvement i can make in the short
amount of time left i'll do it one thing
i know about the marvel team is they
won't stop they'll keep pushing it until
it's as close to being great as it could
he then went on to say that marvel's
been a great team to work with i think
that was not a surprising surprise i've
been super supported by the whole marvel
operation starting on the top of kevin
feige and working all the way down to
the crews that they work with they're
super professional and have supported me
every step of the way now the way this
is worded is it sounds like he has a lot
of creative control which i know will
make a lot of fans happy we want to see
sam rami do his own thing his spider-man
films for fantastic so seeing him back
in a direct and role just makes him
really happy and really excited to see
what he'll do i hope after this film
he'll go on to direct more marvel
projects but i guess we'll just have to
wait and see now regarding the reshoots
i know a lot of people have been
concerned about these but i will tell
you most films actually do undergo
reshoots i guess not to the same level
as the doctor strange movie but
according to rumors these reshoots were
um because they'll add in more cameos to
the movie because apparently this movie
is going to have a lot of cameos so so
try not to get them spoiled and i'm just
excited to see what they're going to be
anyway that's about it for this video
guys so if you haven't already please
like and subscribe and turn
notifications on to show your support
thanks for watching guys